i've been drawing up my indifference
curves to look something like this so
that's the vertical axis that's one good
so this is the quantity of good a this
is the quantity of good b and i've been
drawing the indifference curves like
this so it might look like that that's
one indifference curve then another
indifference curve would look like that
and i could keep drawing in difference
curves and this is what an indifference
curve would look like for two normal
goods let me write that down normal
these are normal goods and the reason
why normal goods and difference curves
would look like that or when i'm trying
to figure out the combinations of two
normal goods is because if i have a lot
of one good so this point right over
here i have a lot of good a and i have
very little of good b i would be willing
to trade off a lot of a to get one extra
b
but if all of a sudden i have a lot of b
and a lot less a i you would have to
give i would be willing to trade off
very little a to get an incremental b so
that's why we have kind of this this
inward bow shaped curve right over here
or you could you know mathematically it
looks like it's part of a hyperbola and
so that's what normal goods the
indifference curves between if you're
trading off between normal goods would
look like now let's think about the
indifference curve so it would be this
kind of curve thing the the marginal
rate of substitution would constantly be
changing now let's think about
different types of goods let's say that
this was
let's say that this is the quantity
quantity of
five dollar bills five dollar bills and
let's say that this is the quantity the
quantity of ten dollar bills
ten dollar bills and we're talking about
the actual the good now is actually the
dollar bills so
let's say so let's say this right over
here is
10 5 bills well that's 50 bucks i'd be
indifferent between that and
ten dollar bills
so this is five right over here and any
point in between i would be indifferent
because i'm always willing to trade off
two five dollar bills for one ten dollar
bill so it would look my indifference
curve would be linear in this case
my indifference curve would
would be
linear
so no matter what on this indifference
curve i'm always willing if i want to
get one extra 10 bill i'm always willing
to give up two five dollar bills which
makes complete sense because two five
dollar bills are completely equivalent
to one ten dollar bill and we could take
it to another extreme let's say i have
let's say i have an indifference well
let me draw the quantity
the quantity of i don't know the
quantity of m m's
quantity of m and m's
of let's say let's say red m m's
red
red m m's
and i should have done that in red but i
won't and then let's say this is the
quantity of blue m m's and let's say
that i actually am indifferent between
red and blue eminem some people aren't
red m ms and blue m ms so having 10 red
m m's is to me is completely equivalent
of having 10 blue m m's so i i'm willing
to trade them off one for one i don't
care i get the same total utility
i get the same total utility so in this
case assuming that i really don't care
but the color of my m m i am completely
indifferent as i swap them out and so
this is a case of perfect substitutes
perfect
perfect substitutes
substitutes now i'd always be happy to
have more m ms so another indifference
curve might look something like this
might look something like this but it's
always going to have a slope of negative
one i almost giving up one red m m to
get one blue m m then i would be
indifferent and likewise over here you
could have another indifference curve
between between five dollar bills and
ten dollar bills that looks like this
that looks like this but the slope would
be the exact same thing
now the last situation i want to think
about is
what we'll call perfect complements so
goods that if you have one of them you
really need the other one otherwise one
of one of the two is somewhat useful and
maybe the most pure version of perfect
compliments let me write it over here
perfect
perfect compliments
complements
so let's say that this is the quantity
of right shoes
so the quantity of right shoes and this
is the quantity of left
of left shoes
so obviously
you if we're talking about just one pair
you have one of each now do you care if
you really get more left shoes no you
have the exact same preference it
doesn't really change your life you have
the same total utility in fact it might
even be negative because you have to
store them all but let's just assume you
have the same total utility and you
don't get any benefit of having those
spare shoes in case your shoe gets
destroyed or anything like that in terms
of what you can get out of it what you
can wear you get the same utility and so
you're really indifferent no matter how
many extra no matter how many extra left
shoes someone gives you and you'd also
be indifferent no matter how many extra
right shoes how many right shoes someone
gives you now you would be happier if
you had maybe two right shoes and two
left shoes because now you have two
pairs so this would be another
indifference curve and once again if you
have two right shoes you really don't
care how many more than two left shoes
you get and if you have two left shoes
you really don't care how many more than
two right shoes you get so this and this
difference curve in green is clearly
preferable to the one in white but along
each indifference curve it doesn't
benefit you to have three left shoes and
only two right shoes so this is what
perfect complements would look like this
is perfect substitutes and this is
normal goods